hi
sometimes uh i get really good answers
back from these films
and uh
one
i had to
chuckle
to one of the responses i got
but some people got so much knowledge i
wonder if they've lived longer than me
but um i just know by the time of the
reply that they're
perhaps
half my age
anyhow
there's a lot of people out there not
many i don't think
personally from what i've gathered but
there's a few people out there who have
read
everything there is to read about
oceansi about aikido dietary you know
and the whole history
they educate me
i i sometimes write back and say you
should make a film you know you've got
far more knowledge and people would like
to
know
what you've got in your head
anyway i'll get into the point that i
want to make and that is um
you might notice here
i have a
t-shirt
and
[Music]
as i've been offered to teach over the
years
around the globe
when i go there most
well i don't know if it happens now
but most people used to print a t-shirt
to
[Music]
to celebrate the seminar so some would
have dates on them some would have
the organization's name
some would have pictures of their senses
all sorts i think i've had enough
t-shirts i've not really yet to buy many
over the
nearly 50 years of training
so
so i've seen most of the corners of the
world and the practitioners and
practitioners pretty much trained the
same way
whether it's uh
you know in israel or
new zealand uh you know i'm trying to
like go from one side of the
world to the other
in even in japan you know
we're all people and we all see and
think things differently
but one of the points that we've made
and where i commented aikido should be
multiple attack and not
uh
one-to-one
and i see too many
teachers they might be high-ranked
going down on one knee or both knees
so one particular person wrote to me and
said well i've seen uh tomorrow scentsy
and i've seen
you know and
they named these teachers of these
masters of yesteryear
and how they went down on me
what i'd like to say is if i'm teaching
a seminar and i'm teaching
uh where you go from
let's say tap day master sweatpants
that's from standing to sitting
if you do this
um it's to teach
a particular technique
psychosexual teachers these techniques
but the formula
or the whole principle
that you know encompasses
aikido is
multiple attack
you're surrounded by attackers that was
the main construction of those senses
aikido
so when you go down on one knee or two
knees
we used to in the olden days whenever
they were
i don't know if in judo they call it as
well but it's called a sacrifice throw
it's not a sacrifice to the person
you're throwing
it was classed as a sacrifice
of your own body
so i hope you can see that those people
who are still wanting to say yes but you
know i've seen
you know
since
the dosha you can say what you like
about who you saw go down on one knee
but there's different reasons
and that's what i'd like to explain
if they're doing a demonstration
they perhaps have one or two okays and
because it's
powerful the uk's may not be able to
just keep coming back up to throw after
throw
so they'll use two or three uk's and
they just
let one go after a few throws and then
call it upon another one
and that's
not multiple attack that's doing a
demonstration and within that
demonstration the sensei might decide to
go down on one knee or both that's their
prerogative because that's what they're
demonstrating
but the whole
idea of
just going down on one knee because or
two knees oh well they they do
techniques on one knee
they do
a lot of work
in japan only on their knees
this is for hip development as i've said
before
please try and take it out of your mind
this concept of well they go down one
knee
that is classed as a sacrifice of their
own body
and it makes common sense to me i hope
it does to you if you've got
eight attackers
and one
is down and then another one
and then on the third one you go down on
one knee
or two knees
that's when you're putting your own
sacrifice in your body because they're
standing they're going to be coming in
kicking punching hitting you with
baseball bats bars anything like chairs
anything they can
that they can pick up off the street
outside the cafes and that
i know this all sounds very ruthless
but you know
it does happen you just got to you do
enough like you know you'll hopefully be
able to avoid all this
so
it's a sacrifice throw to their own body
when they make that final
going down
you should never go down until the last
person is down or to take the last
person down
but i'd like to add a bit to it
the other day on uh one of my films i
said about why i like watching christian
tissier sheehan
it's because
i always look at his eyes
and i know that he has awareness
i trained with tomorrow scentsy
he had awareness even when he was
smiling you he's smiling at the
crowd of spectators on the mat
but he's watching everything
i remember cytosensei once i invited him
to cambridge we had 252 people training
on the seminar
we were out in the park
something caught his eye he was teaching
something caught his eye going past the
park on the street on the on the actual
road
someone was on a bike
i had to turn my head to see what he was
looking at
but i was
clicked into him enough to know
that while he was teaching he didn't
stop teaching but i could tell that he
sort of just looked
away like that just refocused in a
slightly different direction he didn't
sort of turn his head what's going on
there he just noted that there was
something out of place
and that's what i mean about we
don't have the zan shin when i see these
youtube films or facebook films
these people who are making
demonstrations have a great deal of fun
they do the sacrifice throw in their
dojo with one other uk they're showing
what a great master they are
throwing and pounding their ukis about
but
they're only looking at the one person
they're not
got this wide open freedom
you know you don't have to be intense
you don't have to be
you know paranoid
but you do have to learn
how to have wide vision so when you're
you've got the one person don't narrow
your mind down to that one person keep
open you know if you're doing a coat of
gosh this is good because you can see
all around you as you move
but if you just turn and you're not
actually looking outwards and
something's gotta almost be thrown at
you for you to notice it
then you're not a very good aikidoka
in my opinion
so there we have it
why go down on one knee or two knees
sacrifice your body if you wish
i hope it doesn't let you down
in the real situation
try to even when one to one
or two opponents try to watch everything
even if it's space with no one there
like i said i've just chosen two no
three masters
who i know are always viewing
even if they're smiling they will see
something
i remember
in in while i wasn't too sure about some
weapons work we were doing
so i tapped myself after since he showed
it i tucked myself well back really
you're supposed to go in the same place
i tapped myself well back behind
somebody
because i didn't want to
be a fool sort of trying to think about
it and do it
no doubt you've been there as well at
some stage
all of a sudden this shouting came
across tony
poured me to the fun
and of course my japanese not so good
he's shouting and shouting in japanese
i quickly asked um
the head dashi there miles kessler
sensei
what's he what says he's saying what's
he and he
wonderfully
quickly in the shortest words possible
telling me what i got correct
and i actually heard that over all my
panic
um
standing there
he
i was a mature adult i think about was
like 45 years old or something but he
brought me down to feeling like i was
worthless nothing
you know a
wet piece of rag on the floor he's
violent shouting but he was my master
that's how much i respected him
and i've always wondered to this day how
did he see me because i know that i
couldn't see him and i was hidden
but he spotted me
that's the sign of a true master
zanjin
whether you
even when you sleep they said you must
keep one eye open
this is perhaps for the fanatics but the
meaning i think
you'll understand
thanks for your time
and i hope you find this of use
please go to my patreon site what you'll
see down below the link if you click on
the more
and you may wish to be a contributor
where the good stuff is thank you bye